欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天盘面的气氛又不一样了
昨天尾盘杀了300多点
今天是往上拉
拉了300多点
今天晚上决战大魔王
就是联准会的利率决策会议
但是今天好奇妙
一开盘量真的好小
可是慢慢的盘中开始点火
似乎预告着
晚上这一关过了
投过深就过
而且这段时间
虽然我们看到量比较小
我们的散户或法人朋友
是比较谨慎的
但官股连续几天大买
一只手一直撑在这里
肯定是知道什么事情
如果说九月有魔咒
那么十月应该要光辉
这个就是历史的惯性
所以今天就要来好好聊聊了
量收到极致
但今天盘中有点火的话
预告着第四季
真的很值得期待
而来宾们怎么选股
各有一套逻辑来欢迎他们
第一位是K线之神
朱家宏 朱老师
好 朱老师也要讲
他也是观察观股的动向
连续几天买了300多亿
这个手笔蛮大的
到底在户哪一些股票
这些股票确实形态不错
那今天呢结算也结算过了
焊测的抽签
锁了快要9000亿的资金
明天全数放出来
活水是不是要到了呢
好 那如果您觉得量不够
百元以下的好股票
今天盘面上非常亮眼
朱老师也帮您挑
进场是水温资金不用多
好第二位呢是好久不见
我们统一投顾的总经理
PCB女王廖婉婷
好婉婷到也要讲
9月好像是有魔咒的
但历年叫光辉10月
那10月就应该光辉
产业的前景继续在发展
半导体展过了
接下来叫做PCB展
就是它的主场
今天展前就先帮我们考前猜题咯
到底上中下游
这一次展览里面会看到什么
以及现在不是涨价题材
现在要走的叫做升级题材
等一下全面帮您做点名
由哪一些女王看好的一次告诉您
好第三位呢
是我们的产业趋势专家
王建文王博
王博也比较乐观哦
他说升息的预期升息的压力
感覺上這幾天其實已經逐步的釋放掉了
接下來把眼光放回產業上面
現在進入到第四季
甚至展望明年什麼東西最重要
今天有成長
明年大成長的
這才是重中之重
CPU今年盤面點火
還有就是設備類股
明年肯定會比今年的成長率大幅拉高
所以等一下王伯偉會告訴你
這兩個產業他看到哪些好股票
首先有請朱老師
你好
好 朱老師
哇 今天一開盤
我看我APP想說回去睡覺好了
但是後面的話盤拉起來了
今天晚上就知道
升息的動向了
還有前瞻指引
還有抽籤 焊測
鎖了快要9000億
明天活水會不會下來
你幫我們挑
關股在戶誰
百元以下型態好的公司
那最近因為很多
有一些不確定的因素
所以大部分看起來比較黏
在這邊上上下下
那國際局勢
看起來越來越亂
怎麼看這件事呢
連阿拉伯都已經開始進招了
對 因為阿拉伯
它只有一個上面 一個下面
現在這兩邊都在出事
都在打仗
所以它的石油被卡住了
那油管又被炸了
所以我們的石油已經怎麼樣
衝過108了
那近期的高點
好幾天了
那甚至還有人看到150
那就過前高了 新高
看到150的話不得了
這個衝膨就會很嚴重
那最近最熱門的事就是這個
幾乎很多人都在問
可不可以去抽籤
你有沒有抽
我沒有抽 我太忙了
一張抽要225萬
對 你還要有兩百多萬去
你可以啊 去抽
但是這個參與的人很多
所以在這裡卡了8600億
台灣人真的太有錢了不過我今天身邊沒人抽中大家都乖乖回來上班因為這個太低太低了這個中籤率比中的透都差不多
好啦 中到的就恭喜他了
那沒有中到你沒損失
錢又回來
這個抽籤的費用
錢回來了
你可以到股市來賺錢
對不對
所以這幾件事情
大概看起來
當然這個我們是沒有辦法去
去干預的
但是這個可以知道的
這幾天光谷也護盤
盡量不要讓它跌得太多
因為跌太多
後面要拉的話壓力就比較大
所以我們在大盤上
其實各位也看得出來這個狀況
我們常常講這個多頭回檔
你看這根下影線
它是不是就拉在這裡
它為什麼要拉
因為這裡有個很重要的支撐
前面這裡有個下影線
這個下影線是大量
是近期最大量
我们量一直在说
所以这个大量如果跌破的话
当然这个对我们的架构来说
就不太好
所以有看到这边有拉
昨天也是没有破
今天再拉
就维持在这个地方不要跌下去
它只要维持住了
那利多出来的话
就像刚刚讲的资金回来
联准会的升息消息过了
这些慢慢淡化的话
它就有机会再往上去勾
所以我们这个礼拜
可能還是一個震盪盤
還要整理
所以什麼原因
因為我們下禮拜
還有一個長假
我們下禮拜是中秋節
對耶
所以在中秋
中秋節前
應該還是一個震盪盤
那這樣中秋以後
它就變了
它就會變盤
朱老師有人說
這個像一個Mtone
你覺得像嗎
對 這是一個短期的
我常講看圖
你要怎麼看
怎麼看
你這個怎麼會M頭啊
這個比這個高耶
我不會看啊
就失敗的學生
M頭的話
第二個頭會比較低啊
原來如此
對 高的話叫多頭回檔
它並沒有
這個高點比前面的高啊
雖然它沒有過歷史高點
但這個也是歷史次高
次高點
中秋節過
變盤的機率非常大
因為各位就知道
這個休息已經一二三四了
我們說跌三四天就不太容易跌
所以這個地方容易止住
甚至於如果明天資金回來
可能還會有一個小的反彈
所以它還是一個
一個區間整理的一個架構
下禮拜中秋連假前
朱老師還會來
所以我們那時候可以再驗證一下
好 那最近我們剛剛看大盤
有好幾根撐在這個地方
那實際上當然大家也會感覺到
因為那個成交量不大
那表示散戶參與的很少
那為什麼又不跌呢
有人在後面
有人在戶盤
不過最近來說
八大光股戶盤比較積極
因為他們買了300多億
4000就買了快400億
那大家也看得到
這個台積電一定是戶盤的主角
今天聯席
對 這個是主角
因為指數就看台積電來撐
那這個是題材
這個題材
目前大家還是看好
需求還沒有下來
那只是短期漲多了
這邊會整理
籌碼會比較亂
那聯發科可能是最近
大家比較關注的
除了台積電就是聯發科了
對 因為相對強勢
自研晶片
台積電我們也看到
它這個底點一直都沒有破
但這邊的高點也一直沒有過
其實它的最高點
也是它的次高點
跟我們的大盤一樣
再上去就是
這個歷史高點
那在這邊整理久了
那個大盤穩住了
那最後要攻關
還是要靠台積電
那聯發科今天
走了半場的好戲
因為盤中他收盤最高點是
站上五軍
那站上五軍就回後買上漲
因為這多頭啊 對不對
這個是不是多頭
這是多頭啊
那回一檔如果今天站上
那他就是一個回後買上漲
尾盤可能有一些賣壓還是沒有站上所以不行嗎沒有站上我們就等他前幾天這個紅K也是沒站上可是它回來月線有支撐
還有現在這個上升切線
所以它還是有空間讓它修正的
並沒有破壞
它可以回到這邊漲都可以
那我們等它確認
確認站上
那它是一個目前來說
算是結構 架構都算比較好的
如果有興趣的話
只是它價位比較高
它比台積電還貴
對 因為它超車了
但前景成長性很看好
那我們剛剛講華方店跟那個南亞科
都是空投
因為這個壓力沒過
這個下面的支撐又跌破了
這邊跌破了
所以它現在今天是要反彈
那反彈各位也看得到
這個大阪整區
那這個都是壓
所以短線上有可能在這邊
可能在這邊再整理一下
放量衝出去
再去挑戰它的歷史高點
好 那維穎剛剛有講
其實盤中幾殺
發生什麼事呢
有人說墨西哥單掉了
真的啊
有這麼說法
有那邊掉單這樣
那我們那邊做股票
可能不是每個人資訊
都這麼靈光
這很難 真的
盤中我也不知道什麼
沒有辦法知道這麼多的資訊
可是我們就技術分析來講
前面已經告訴你有人在賣了
这个最高点有大量在卖
对不对 而且卖出来黑黑
那如果你是做技术面的
没有去研究基本面或什么
那这个是买点
所以这个地方的第二天跌破五均
是卖点
所以基本上你是获利出厂
那获利出厂后来就没有买点了
对 他就一直跌
那这个已经跌破月线
但是就趋势来讲
它还是落头
為什麼我們講趨勢
是講頭轉折高低點
所以這個低點沒有跌破
所以各位看
這一天是不是會拉一個下影線
真的 對
就在那裡
因為它剛好就跌到這個
轉折的低點
那只要在這邊
不要再繼續把這個跌破
過兩天季線就上來了
那看季線可不可以撐住
那第三個它跌到這
就我們的技術分析的慣性來說
這個叫低檔
就是說你做空
你不能在這做
這個跌到低檔就容易反彈
它就容易上來
假設它沒有跌破
又上來的話
它還是多頭啊
這個叫回後買上漲
沒錯吧
我們平常也是這樣講的
只要你回來不要跌破前提
那回後買上漲
你站上五軍也站上越線
所以它還是一個買點
只不過這個買點上面壓力比較重
但是今天它有出量
對
今天這個量如果站上了
它就有機會去挑戰
但是沒有站上
它就变压力了
你如果再跌破了
这又被套牢了
又一堆人被套牢
所以你如果对这次有兴趣的
当然我刚刚讲几个条件
一定要成立
你才可以动
第一个你要站上去
站上武军 站上越线
第二个如果能继续放量
那就更好
那就表示
我们知道了
背后可能有利多
或者高档有卖压
可能这些慢慢地消化掉了
那市場還是認同
那它還是有機會去挑戰這個高點
好 因為今天盤中殺下來的時候
很多人說怎麼了
可是真的沒有聽到什麼消息
是下午才說
maybe 也許
但最好是從圖看
反而覺得指跌點快到了
對 在我們來講
技術分析你聽到的消息一定是落後
可是我們看技術面
我不知道後面有什麼利空
可是按技術來說
跌破五均我就賣
按紀律走
對 這個叫紀律
那后面有利空
那你就可以观察说
这个利空对这个技术分析
有没有影响
如果它有影响
它就不会上来了
它就下去了
那下去我们也不会做
今天因为成交量
最近比较小败
原下股票反而比较活泼
没错
那这个就叫多头上涨
它既然上涨
我们就可以追踪
那还有一个多头
回后上涨
回后上涨就今天是好的点那至於台塑世保來說現在只有台塑化還比較好其他的都趨勢都改了
有的空有的是盤整
已經進到
只有這個台塑化是多頭的回檔
所以還可以等它上升
可以等上
所以我們的目標確認了
那你就在這裡面找
還是好的多頭可掉
好 我們朱老師
有在8月找到一檔標股
真的很誇張
他真的是漲的跟台股的
漲相完全不同
黎一光
8月26號到現在漲了快5成
還有被動員演的小標兵信倉電
9月9號漲了快兩成了
這支比較標的厲害
這支真的誇張
今天還漲停
只有在這裡你休息一下
就天天啊
這個比較難做
漲兩天又跌
漲一天又跌
漲一天又上影線
所以這一支股票你要做到
能够一直报到是比较不容易
都是等回后买
两只趋势不变
大家有的就许报
那当然虽然我们很早前就讲了
但是它现在趋势不变
所以我们还是可以说
而且也并没有涨到太离谱 太高
我们再来看其他的低价股
这个都跟CPU有关
负财跟群床
所以刚才有讲
这个就今天就买一点
今天刚好回
今天是买一点
这是多头回答
那今天有放量
那籌碼當然還是錯
大戶一直增加
那今天是買點
因為它在月線
昨天跌破今天站上
它是標準的今天的買點
但買的就按照紀律做
那沒有買就不要追高
你不要明天拉到壓力這邊
你又去追
你就等下一次
群創整理好久
對 這邊在整理
是不是看起來不太對勁
不會 這很好
對啊 這個在打底
打底為什麼不公
還有一個均線壓力還沒有劃進
季線在上面彎
這個季線還彎的
所以做這種股票其實也很簡單
你看大量的地方是不是在這
這個大量
這個地方跟這個大量是不是一樣的
所以這個突破就可以了
要往好處想是不是
你畫一條壓力線
這叫壓力
要突破壓力
這個最高的位置
其實就是52.5
這條灰色的52.5
你這裡畫條壓力線
不管它這裡整理多久
如果你有一天收盤前
你看到紅K4頂棒突破
那這個底就做完了
那我們從這個位置也知道
如果你突破當然就上季線
因為季線現在已經下來了
只要你一突破你就上季線
而且月線是往上的
所以這個其實是一個鎖股的好股票
好股票 你所在這裡
因為它這個最低點是有量的
這裡有成交量的
那最近看起來
是有人在買了
大戶有在加持
所以他沒有買很多
就是因為我剛剛講
季線還有壓
但已經有人在這裡偷偷買
買的人的規劃
應該就跟我講的一樣
他就在等那個突破
那說不定突破他會去加碼
因為他底部已經買了
那突破他就去加碼
那當然這是另外一個所謂的
操作的策略
那我剛剛講台塑化
它是回檔
是
月線 季線
我們就等回後買上漲
那星星這支股票
就這個籌碼看還不錯
但就趨勢來講
我剛剛有講都進到盤整
因為這個是頭頭低
這邊是底底高
那你就化好就行了
我們只要把資深壓力化好
你就知道在哪個位置你才可以買
那沒有的話你就等一等
那如果下來當然各位也不會買
股價跌大家都會害怕
股價漲才想追
但你也要追到剛剛那個關鍵的位置
是 好不好
當然欣欣的話
也是因為現在中東很亂
然後這個航運的運價上漲
所以大家也要同步
可能關心一下運價的狀況
大概航運股現在都走這樣
是
都是這樣盤子
所以你如果對陽明有興趣
那你就把它畫好
一樣可以等這個機會
是 好 直接非常謝謝
朱老師的教學 謝謝